how about some props tonight as tom
brady and the buccaneers go to chicago
to face nick foles and the bears these
odds are provided by points bet
sportsbook the official sports betting
partner of nbc sports all right first
one simple more passing yards tom brady
or nick falls yeah this is a good one um
you know
both defenses are very good both front
fours are very good and dominant they
are
i think i'm going to go with
nick foles here just because the bucks
will take a few more chances
in in their coverage and they're a
little young in the back end i like
their talent but they're young and raw
and like we saw last week in that
chargers game they let up some big plays
they've kind of let up some big plays in
every game really so i'm gonna go with
foals too and also into that why i think
that i just don't think there's any way
the bears o line there's no way they're
gonna run on that bucks front you know
this this bucks team i mean you know
like i said yesterday watch out because
it just looks like it's all kind of
going in the right direction and they
got talent and uh
i think you and i both look at them as
the third best team in the nfc right now
all right bonus topic between the two
quarterbacks which one will have more
receiving yards
well i think that's
that time is gone for brady where i
don't think they'll even call a play for
him anymore i think we've realized
that's not his cup of tea so i'm gonna
go with nick foles on that one too but
what do you think about the yards what
do you think's gonna happen there
you know i think it's going to be brady
yeah i really do no it's hard
right
it's his first prime time game
away from new england he will be keenly
aware of that he's keenly aware of the
fact of what nick foles did to him the
last time he faced foals i think brady's
going to be
very motivated tonight very prime
tonight now the problem is he's got some
banged up receivers yeah but
he'll make it happen yeah okay i got
fulfilled good there you still got water
going down the wrong tube you good i'm
fine i'm fine it's always better when
your co-host points it out as you're
fighting through it that's what we do
that's what we do
yeah tom tom brady i i still when he
runs i expect to hear john fasenda's
voice because it looks like he's in slow
motion and in recent years i've noticed
that when he runs
it looks like he's wearing ski boots
like he's chasing his skis down the
mountain i mean he just it's just for as
great as a quarterback as he is it's
very ungainly when it's time for him to
try to move
although he had a nice little you know
he yeah on one of his ti the touchdown
pass to mike evans in the back of the
end zone feels good
i know he's moving pretty well yeah he
he i almost thought he was going to run
it that's how well he was moving all
right first to throw an interception
tonight tom brady or nick foles um
i i i think um
i'll go with nick foles here i will i
will i mean brady's of course throwing
some interceptions we know that uh i
think he'll be careful with the football
though i do i i you know this is an
interesting matchup because of these
defenses and what they do
uh but
yeah i'm gonna go nick falls i think
nick foles is gonna get caught in some
moments where the pressure around him
will just be so tough he's going to have
to he'll get hit as he throws or he's
going to be people all around him as
he's throwing and it'll be an errand
pass something like that
i agree with you on that one as well all
right more receiving yards mike evans of
the buccaneers or alan robinson of the
bears i'm going to go with alan robinson
listen i don't i'm not and i know i seem
to be picking the bears here in this
it's just the way they get the match-up
sets up you know the bears are they're
defense they're past defense
they don't like put a lot of guys in the
box and go we're gonna stop the run they
play to kind of stop the pass and put a
lot of faith in their front seven to
kind of just stop the run by themselves
and you know i already talked about a
little bit of the young guys in that
that tampa secondary and everything that
that way i'm gonna go with allen
robinson because i would just think that
fuller is matched up against mike evans
they're gonna really be all over him
because of some of the banged up people
in that buccaneers uh wide receiving
core like you mentioned to where i'll go
allen robinson yeah and just so we're on
the same page about these injuries mike
evans questionable with an ankle that he
injured and it looked bad when it
happened against the charges on sunday
he did you've got chris godwin out with
a hamstring he'll miss his second
straight game scottie miller is
questionable with hip and groin injuries
he's a guy you can count on to catch a
deep pass in every game justin watson
number 17 who flashes from time to time
he's out with a chest injury wow rob
gronkowski has a shoulder injury but he
has no designation on the final report
which would be howard
oj howard's out for the year he's not
even on the injury report he's on into
reserve lesean mccoy is out for the game
with an ankle injury and leonard
fournette is doubtful with an ankle
injury so a lot of the weapons simply
not available to the buccaneers and tom
brady tonight short week
not enough time for some of these guys
to fully heal i suspect mike evans will
play i suspect scottie miller will play
which is helpful right but uh you know
it's not ideal for the tampa bay
buccaneers as they try to get before and
it's an interesting game because you
know it really you know it's it's um
it's one of those things where i think
the bucks are the better football team
but chicago matches up well with the
bucks they they have some things that
they'll be able to look at i think
and go well we feel good in this area we
can keep this game close it'll be about
their offense and nick foles eventually
i mean it's going to come down to that i
really do can that bears a line that got
absolutely
mauled last week by deforest buckner and
the colts you know they got a same type
of group coming in here right now with
jpp shaq barrett vaida via and then dama
consu they will they will push you
around and that to me is where the game
will be won can the bearzo line just
hang in there and not let them ruin the
game if not they have a chance but if
they do ruin it watch out
i still think it's veda veya although
every time i hear you say vitavia i
don't know it is veto
right why would you listen to any
english that comes out of my mouth the
point might be right the enunciations of
things you know that's questionable
veta veya and the buccaneers defensive
line yeah and at least it's not as bad
as danielle hunter who actually may
indeed end up missing the season so you
don't have to worry about saying to neil
hunter's name for the rest of the year
if that's the case last one rob
gronkowski over under
receiving yards tonight
37.5 he is averaging 22 yards receiving
per game this year i'm gonna go under i
gotta see it first to believe it there i
i do just you know again
we've seen we saw a little bit better
movement we talked about two days ago i
think it was in gronkowski where at
least it look it looked better but i'm
not sitting here going oh he's a weapon
yet or anything like that but he he
might be getting there maybe we're like
three weeks from now we start to go okay
here's gronk we're we're starting to see
the old guy a little
well with all these guys injured yeah oj
howard out right right
there's a necessity for grog to do more
than just pat
then pass block or run block
the the play last week i went back and
watched that over and over again yeah
the one thing i have to give him credit
for he made the catch in traffic oh yeah
there have been opportunities earlier in
the year for him to make big catches in
traffic and he just you know it's he was
off for a year but i still watch him
fire off the line chris and it just
feels
like i'm watching tom brady trying to
get you you're right it is it's just not
it's not and and so when is it going to
be there when do you reach your maximum
because
he's been in this now for two months
setting aside whatever he did or didn't
do in the offseason working with tom
brady they showed up late july
it's now october the 8th yeah he's had
time to get in shape right
is this is this as good as it's gonna
get and and tonight is the night here's
the thing yeah every other game they've
played
hasn't been under that microscope of the
spotlight of national television and
this is the first thursday night game
that gets the blowout treatment the
other ones were nfl network only this
one is the fox nfl network amazon
extravaganza yeah so everything gronk
does is gonna be watched and i tell you
what if i'm fox i put a camera on gronk
i want to see how he's moving i want to
be able to have troy aikman say this
guy's running like he used to or he's
not running like he used to because the
he's not in shape yet thing i think that
ship has sailed i think he's in as good
of shape as he's ever going to be in
right now and if anything its injuries
are going to slow him down over the
course of the rest of the season he's
not going to get in better shape and
suddenly become faster yeah right no i i
think everything you said is like 100
you know dead accurate only thing i'll
say to it is like
you do get in shape and you might take a
little bit to where okay i've gotten in
shape and now
i've got to become explosive again right
and that could that to me is where i'm
i'm gonna look at like to what you're
saying when he comes off the ball yeah
it looks kind of like okay here we go
come on now truck keep it going here we
go like he's like gotta like you know
build up speed that way so we'll see i
think the next two to three weeks like i
said i think will be very telling to go
okay
whoa we saw a jump or no this is just
what it is this is who he is now and
don't expect anything more i think we're
getting to that point to where i i won't
be able to say oh he's not quite back in
the swing of things or whatever you're
right and i'll be watching that tonight
be interesting to see how that goes they
love throwing seam routes you know tight
ends right up the the hashes or slot
receivers up to hashes brady's great at
that it's where he always hit gronk it's
where gronk had the catch last night or
last week he had the drop pass too but
all they like doing that i don't know if
the bears defensive scheme will lend to
a lot of that that's why i was a little
scared to go with that over on the uh
37.5 yards receiving
i'll go over just because i think
they'll come up with ways to get the
ball in his hands because they need to
but you know when he takes those first
couple steps off the line of scrimmage
he just has that look of a guy
who used to be a lot faster
isn't now and can't quite understand it
and is trying to like try harder like
maybe i'll be faster if i really try
harder coming out of the gates and
that's just that's not how it works
speed is something you either have
or you don't have and once it's gone
it's gone and and he's in the process
anger denial bargaining depression and
acceptance of realizing that he's not as
fast as he used to be so he's gonna have
to figure out how to work
within the the boundaries of of what
skills he currently has but uh whether
it was the year off whether it's the
accumulation of injuries or whether it's
his father time is catching him a hell
of a lot faster than catching his
quarterback gronk is not the guy chris
that he that he used to be uh but he
still i think can help that team and i
will go over tonight just because yeah
he's one of the he's one of the only
healthy bodies in the in the passing
game yeah no i i think that there's
something to watch you're right i mean
that'll tell us
where evans is and all those type of
things but yeah if they feel like oh
they're not a hundred percent we better
have a you know a section in my play
sheet this week that's get the ball to
gronk and special plays for him there
that could this could be the week uh
with the status of where their wide
receivers are at and everything like
that no doubt
on that gronk point a bonus question
yeah the veteran slash old tight end
more likely to have a touchdown tonight
rob gronkowski for the buccaneers or
jimmy graham for the bears remember
there was a time
these two were the marquee tight ends in
the national football league there was
that year where they were going back and
forth for the all-time tight end
receiving yardage record remember that
was 2011 i think yep which one's more
likely to score touchdown i mean jimmy
graham's a specimen too when i was
working in new england the saints and
sean payton and drew brees came up there
and we had like you know a days of uh
practices and scrimmages before the
preseason game jimmy graham's one of
those guys where
i mean he's bigger than gronk i don't
think people realize that he is a really
big guy now he's not nearly as physical
as gronk is
i'm gonna go with jimmy graham on this
one that's another one i just got to see
it first before i uh give gronk anything
that way you know graham has been a oh
we get inside the 10 and we'll just
throw it up for you guy for the chicago
bears and
i could see that happening tonight with
the way the bucks play and and kind of
leave their guys one on one a lot where
he could get that opportunity once again
i've always been a big jimmy graham fan
and i don't know what the issue's been
in recent years i it irritated me when
he went to seattle
and and they were they were complaining
that he doesn't block yeah
that's not what he never does that's
right that's that's not what he does
he's also not playing quarterback right
so i mean it just and i never liked that
but but uh he's always had a good way
about him he's got a great story you
know and he used to post the videos i
think he may still do of him flying all
sorts of different planes which always
makes me nervous to see but but uh i
hope he does well tonight and it's good
to see him having some success three
touchdowns so far for the chicago bears
this this year but but another little
rank one another reason to get excited
about tonight's game definitely better
than last week's game what
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports